My name is George Gachara. I am a Global Change
maker from Kenya. I actually believe that
the World Cup will really mean a lot to Kenya,
I mean to Africa and specifically South Africa
in two ways, two fundamental ways. One is
the economy, the other one is cultural exchange.
The economy of Africa should be more or less
improved by consumption because we have a
lot of people coming into Africa, into South
Africa and into the neighboring countries
around South Africa for accommodation, for
food, for travel, for tour, around the time
of World Cup. And also cultural exchange that
Africa should not be seen as jungle with lions
all over but with people and cultures that
are progressive with their infrastructure
and the opportunities that exist in Africa.
So I think the World Cup is pretty a good
thing and also it should elevate our soccer
and our standards also of infrastructure of
communication and security must also increase
the same. So that's my opinion. Thank you.